[Música]
nos vamos hasta el gigante asiático para
seguir analizando la situación en
shanghai una ciudad con más de 25
millones de habitantes y uno de los
motores económicos de china que es ahora
el centro de un nuevo rebrote con 19 que
desafía la estricta política cero
cobista y todas las autoridades los
habitantes de la urbe se encuentran
confinados desde el pasado 28 de marzo y
ahora sufren de ansiedad desesperación
también enfrentan la escasez de los
alimentos y los productos de primera
necesidad la situación es realmente
tensa por lo que hoy el ministerio de
transporte de china aseguró que se
centrará en resolver los problemas
pendientes de la cadena de suministro en
áreas clave como esta ciudad como
shanghai afirmó que debido a las medidas
de prevención de la pandemia se ha
producido atascos logísticos y para ello
entonces quiero saludar a nuestra
segunda invitada el día ella es micaela
toxin modelo argentina confinada en un
hotel en esta ciudad en shanghai gracias
micaela por atendernos por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de francia
24 que está ocurriendo realmente en
shanghai escríbanos su experiencia
durante todos estos días confinada
hola hola muy buenos días
básicamente la situación es que hace 19
días por lo menos desde el área nacional
y sólo estamos en cuarentena en loudon
como ustedes acá
no tenemos acceso a los supermercados a
las farmacias no podemos salir del
departamento solo abandonamos el lugar
cuando tenemos que hacernos cada 48
horas
pcr
ahí va a cansar el lobby del edificio
nos sumamos a la fila no miso pan y de
ahí volvemos al departamento es que el
único momento en el que podemos
abandonarlo o cuando tenemos que bajar
para recibir los suministros del
gobierno eso le quería preguntar
dice usted que no tienen acceso a
farmacias para sus medicinas o para los
alimentos como hacerle no sé una lista
al gobierno ustedes le pueden hacer una
lista al gobierno diciéndole necesito
está este alimento o esta medicina o
simplemente lo que ellos quieran
no si pudiésemos hacerle una lista le
hubiese mandado algo así que no es algo
que se puede hacer
acá de las mandas lo que los quieren
aquí necesita de cada persona de los 25
millones de habitantes en shanghai se
por hacer una limpia lo ve acá no abasto
uno recibe lo que se tiende a andar no
hay un día específico no se sabe cuándo
se puede llegar a recibir soles casi
veinte días hoy fue la tercera vez que
recibí
y bueno otras cosas es como la compañía
con la que trabajo se ha encargado de
demandar me dicen los alimentos la
embajada argentina se contactó conmigo
pero no ayuda por si necesitaba algo que
ellos hablaran con el área donde vivo
porque obviamente la barrera lingüística
es muy grande y yo venía por nada más
cuatro meses aquí y se extendió con esto
de la cuarentena y hay muchas cosas de
trance de no sé a dónde hay que pedir no
sé qué hacer entonces ellos gracias a
dios me entiendan do su ayuda claro lo
decía también porque hay muchísimas
personas que están confinadas sobre todo
no no no las personas jóvenes por
adultos mayores que sí necesitan como lo
mejor un régimen alimentario porque
padecen de una enfermedad o algún o
algún tipo de medicina en específico
porque me imagino que pues las autorías
atienden a estas a estas personas en
particular esperamos que sea así pero
también hay descontento hay
desesperación en las personas hemos
podido ver obviamente en los medios de
comunicación en las redes sociales las
personas pues ya desesperadas por este
confinamiento realmente es así o no todo
el mundo está ya desesperado queriendo
salir cómo es la situación de las
personas el ánimo después de tanto
confinamiento y devenir del
confinamiento inicial el 2020
bueno con respecto a esto tengo que
decir que en sassari es la primera vez
que pase cuestionamiento hace dos años
con el gobierno sólo cerraron la ciudad
de wuhan donde se originó el virus y las
ciudades de haití cutter seis mosquitos
tenemos una plaga de mosquitos en esta
época y las ciudades de alrededor pero
esta es la primera vez que éstos tienen
en confinamiento aquí en shanghai los
ánimos al principio bueno eran bueno
decía bueno no se va a pasarnos a pasar
estas alturas incluso tanto cansados
nerviosos ansiosos no nos vemos la hora
de que de que se termine por salir a la
calle de retomar la vida la vida normal
y en mi caso poder tomarme un vuelo de
regreso a mi país que dice las
autoridades hasta cuándo se podría
tener este confinamiento cuando se
podría terminar el confinamiento que
actualmente viven ustedes en shanghai
no hay una fecha final no dicen nada
sobre esto ellos lo que tienen es la
idea de kobe pero gracias a dios los
casos antes trabajar la semana pasada el
físico máximo que estamos promediando
era de 29 mil casos al día la mayoría
sintomáticos y hoy estamos en más o
menos 19 mil lo que es un gran avance
pero bueno como os dije estos quieren
tiene la política de kobe pero así que
eso no estoy muy segura de cuándo esto
podría llegar a terminar lo que sí sé es
que algunas áreas de shanghai no están
siendo liberadas todo depende de si en
el área en los últimos 20 días un casco
por ejemplo en mi área han habido muchos
casos entonces por supuesto en este
libre pero en otras áreas donde no han
habido en los últimos 20 días hasta
pueden salir del departamento de todas
formas
no sirve ser libre significa que puede
salir de su departamento pero todo está
cerrado no se puede ir a ningún lado no
hay transporte así que más o menos lo
mismo claro micaela y económicamente
también como está haciendo usted en el
caso particular o personas que con la
que ha podido hablar que también están
confinadas para poder mantenerse usted
me decía que iba solamente por cuatro
meses para un algo puntual y ahora esto
se ha extendido y obviamente pues sin
sin poder producir o sin poder hacer
pues la tarea que usted quería hacer
cuando cuando está ya la parte económica
también pues se ve se ve mermada o sea
como es realmente esa parte
si incluso por supuesto el modelo vine a
trabajar los primeros tres meses para un
montón saber porque cuando uno llega al
final tiene que hacer 14 o 21 días de
cuarentena en un hotel en este momento
estudiando un departamento pero
económicamente si afecta y nos afecta a
todos o con esto he perdido muchos
trabajos perdí vuelos que estoy pidiendo
que sean reembolsados pero las
aerolíneas muy difíciles
de recibir el dinero en tiempo forma nos
afecta a todos personal y
globalmente yo creo